nothing is going to bring back the
feeling of your first Dark Souls
playthrough that's the most depressing
line I think I've ever started a video
with but it's the truth however I think
the remaster could come close and he is
how so the past few days I've been
playing a Dark Souls mod that scatters
enemies and items not in a random manner
but in a calculated well-designed way
it's similar to what scholar of the
first sin did but perhaps even better
because Dark Souls 1 was actually really
well designed to begin with this mod by
FT Richter is my argument for why the
remaster should switch things up and I
think this encounter
coming up on screen sums it up best and
it's simple
I want that item the Black Knight is
guarding and usually I wouldn't items
moving around makes every corner of the
world worth exploring again and it makes
skippable enemies worth fighting and a
few minutes later I realized that that
Black Knight had spotted me on the next
balcony and had come to ambush me it
went on to make this fight with the ball
denied unwinnable which led to me
fleeing towards the blacksmith which led
to me hoping they'd fix back steps in
the remaster but it was a new encounter
in an old game and that's what I want to
play for also the giant dad is in the
forest and so is oroboro those were good
names now there is a huge swath of
people who say they don't want any
gameplay changed for the remaster and I
can kind of understand that they want
the dark souls they remember and they
probably want new players to the series
to experience exactly what they did
seven years ago but to them I say well a
new experience with items and enemies
moved around ironically is the Dark
Souls I remember I remember going around
corners with my shield ax only to get
backstabbed by an enemy that I a garrote
mind me I remember taking stupid risks
for that item over there because it
could be something amazing I remember
crying out where the [ __ ] is the bonfire
after going through half of sense
fortress tents because of all the
progress I was about to lose those are
all things we experienced the first time
we played Dark Souls and those are all
the things I experienced when I played
this mod so ironically I think the more
they tweak the remaster the more
familiar the experience will be but any
item or enemy randomizer mod can give
you those feelings really what made this
mod in particular special is that the
changes have this really good flavor to
them it's the little things like this
holo that gets crushed by the dragon
when you enter the bone
or the bridge then always got bombarded
with projectiles now having an item in
the middle it's being ready to chill
during the moonlight butterfly fight
then realizing that they threw a stone
Sentinel on the bridge to slow you down
if you don't kill it fast enough it's
dying to the an all under arches and
then learning from your mistakes and
dying to the a no wonder arches and
trying to learn from your mistakes and
dying to the an Orlando arches but then
getting lucky and making it past the
Enel under watches I love it and hate it
vanilla and there's actually a lot you
can do from a law perspective by just
putting NPCs in certain locations for
example there was always two other new
londo sealers mentioned alongside Ingrid
one alongside Law Trek and the other
famously had her set discoverable in
black town why not make her an npc at
the base of black town and the missing
daughter of Kaos now guards the entrance
to Quelaag ingeniously placed between
these two egg burdened who you risk hair
growing if you're not careful during
your fight with her and if there are any
items they absolutely should move around
its key items and embers my search for
the lodge and brought me all the way
down to where the basilisks are where no
experienced player in their right mind
would go again
and I started to discover all the cut
enemies that the Creator had put down
here like the butcher hollows and these
Kaos hollows with the Krag spider coming
out of their back there's just so much
room for creativity and I hope the devs
jump at this chance the original Dark
Souls will always be playable after all
but tasteful changes to the remaster
could make this amazing but all this
said it's de lacked that feeling of
playing alongside hundreds and thousands
of other people and that's why whether
they change a lot or a little
in this remaster the remaster is still
gonna feel damn good to play and is
worth looking forward to but before I go
on I wanted to make you guys aware of
something else and that's next month's
Humble Bundle
where you can get Dark Souls 3 plus the
ashes of our E&L dlc for just $12 that's
insanely cheap and I think it's an
amazing deal for those of you who want a
gift the Dark Souls 3 experience to a
friend or maybe you're a console player
and you're looking to make the switch to
PC you can't go wrong for 12 bucks and
that's not all because if you subscribe
before March 2nd you'll also receive the
other titles that they're bundling with
Dark Souls 3 which are often these great
indie titles that you should be playing
anyway last month for example had snake
paths and Al Boy which I both really
enjoyed and both received awesome
critical acclaim you guys know I only
take sponsorships from companies that I
believe in and humble is one of them
support developers support charity
vastly increase your gaming library
every month and support me if you click
the links down below so where do you
stand on the remaster right now we're
still waiting on a bit of information so
we could potentially have everything
I've mentioned in this video when we
could have none of it personally I'd
love to see them keep the game almost
identical mechanically but then go even
further by shifting the balance of the
game by buffing and nothung certain
items and spells in the game there's so
many weapons and spells I'd love to try
and build a character around anyway I
bet we're gonna say some footage really
soon and I'll talk to you about it again
then
for now thanks for sticking with me this
month my videos were recently disrupted
by a short trip that I went on and then
I came back with really intense food
poisoning and the bout of low motivation
but I'm back and I'm ready to go hard at
it I love you guys this was a short
video to tide you over while I work on
the timeline video that patrons voted
for so I'll see you then most likely
[Music]
you